[Music]
good day ladies and gentlemen this is
aan AR Auto today we are working on a
on that
pilot the customer has a key a working
key the customer has a key the remote is
it's not
functional can
actually start the
car so wanted to add a new key to the to
the car it does not be programmed as you
can
see it does not be programmed and it
cannot start the
car see went
[Music]
off what
this
so we're going to add it
key get
foree on know
automatic
selection right
thing BL
key can see hold that pilot
so so let us do animal St
scan and let us check the system
for any for
code sit for split Key System
okay it's a type two immobilizer system
so we are going to add key
[Music]
start the
process start register can the ignition
on the ignition is already on and that
is the registered key
[Music]
there mobilizer system truck success R
key
number success
success sop ignition within 15 seconds
hello ignition is off turn ignition on
using a registered key B it's
on I know
[Music]
off to the
program hello
B when I
first of
check when I come back to shop maybe I'm
bring I
check I come I go
[Music]
I all right no
does the mobilizer light go out
imobilizer light is
out yes
so as you can see the
key the key programming process is
completed the immobilizer light is off
so we are going to test
it where the car started this is the new
key that was
added this is a new kit this is a new
kit that was
added um this is the old
key now one start the
car so we are going to test the remote
function right
d
[Music]
now
remote system get
problem your car the wireless receiver
not
there you not get the receiver for your
car the wireless receiver the they
receive the signal from remote you not
for your car
[Applause]
[Music]
right so the system didn't complain that
initially before you
[Music]